>> Tucker: THE MUSLIM
POPULATION OF THE WEST IS
RISING VERY QUICKLY AND THAT
HIS IMPLICATIONS FOR
NATIONAL COTION IN NATIONAL
SECURITY.
IT’S ALSO INFLUENCING
FASHION.
MACY’S HAS HE ANNOUNCED A
NEW LINE OF FASHIONABLE
MODEST GARB TARGETED AT
MUSLIMS.
MIKEY AND AMERICAN EAGLE
ALREADY HAVE LINES LIKE
THAT.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
-- NEW YORK CITY AND SHE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
>> I’M HAPPY TO BE HERE.
>> Tucker: SO, THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT WAS CHEERED BY
FEMINISTS AND IT GOT ME
THINKING, DO YOU THINK THAT
ISLAM IS A FEMINIST
RELIGION?
>> WELL, WHAT I THINK IS
THAT RELIGION IN EVERY FORM
THROUGHOUT HISTORY HAS
OPPRESSED WOMEN IN MANY
WAYS.
AND ISLAM ISN’T ANY
DIFFERENT WHAT’S STRIKING TO
ME ABOUT THIS NEW LINE OF
MACY’S IS THAT MUSLIM WOMEN
IN THE UNITED STATES HAVE
$44 BILLION IN BUYING POWER.
THAT’S PRETTY SPECTACULAR.
>> Tucker: THAT’S GREAT.
S I’M ALL FOR BUYING POWER.
CLOTHING IS TO PROMOTE
MODESTY AMONG WOMEN.
FOR A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
REASONS.
IT’S IN THE QURAN.
IT’S, OF COURSE, A CENTRAL
PART OF ISLAMIC CULTURE.
SO ARE YOU FOR THAT?
DO YOU THINK WOMEN SHOULD BE
COERCED TO DRESS MODESTLY?
IS THAT A FEMINIST GOAL?
>> I THINK WHAT A FEMINIST
GOAL IS FOR WOMEN TO BE IN
CONTROL OF THEIR LIVES AND
THEIR DESTINIES AND TO HAVE
CHOICES.
SO, WHETHER A WOMAN WANTS TO
WEAR A HIJAB OR SHE DOESN’T
IS REALLY NOT THE POINT.
I THINK WHAT’S REALLY
INTERESTING WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN SEEING.
>> Tucker: WAIT, WAIT.
I’M CONFUSED IT’S NOT THE
POINT.
SO IF I SAY AS ISLAMIC
COUNTRIES DO YOU DON’T HAVE
A CHOICE, YOU HAVE TO WEAR
THE HIJAB BECAUSE YOU NEED
TO BE MODEST AND IF YOU ARE
NOT, YOU COULD GET RAPED AND
IF YOU DO IT’S YOUR FAULT
AND YOU HAVE TO AVERT YOUR
GAZE FROM MEN AND NOT TOUCH
NONRELATIVES WHO ARE MEN.
IS THAT OKAY WITH YOU?
>> I WAS REFERRING TO THE
UNITED STATES.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT’S REALLY
INTERESTING IF YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT’S HAPPENING,
HERE YOU HAVE IN THE UNITED
STATES WOMEN WHO HAD NEVER
DONE ADD HIJAB IN THEIR
ENTIRE LIFE.
AND MARCHED OVER TO JFK
AIRPORT AT THE TIME OF THE
TRUMP TRAVEL BAN AND STARTED
WEARING HIJAB BECAUSE AS A
SYMBOL OF RESISTANCE IN
PROTEST TO THAT.
AT THE SAME TIME THEY ARE
WEARING THEM AS A SYMBOL OF
EMPOWERMENT AND AT THE SAME
TIME YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW IN
IRAN HAVE YOU WOMEN WHO ARE
BRAVELY GETTING UP ON
PLATFORMS AND RIPPING OFF
THEIR HIJAB BECAUSE IT’S
COMPULSE TORE THERE AND THEY
ARE RISKING THEIR LIVES AND
BEING ARRESTED.
>> Tucker: I WOULD AGREE
WITH YOU.
I’M ON THEIR SIDE
COMPLETELY.
WOULD YOU BE, IF MACY’S SOLD
A NEW LINE OF CHINESE FOOT
BINDING SHOES WOULD THAT BE
DIFFERENT TOO.
>> THAT ACTUALLY WOULD
DAMAGE YOUR FEET.
YOU WOULD PROBABLY HAVE TO
GO.
>> Tucker: I DON’T KNOW.
ALL COSMETIC PROCEDURES
DAMAGE THE BODY.
ALL OF THEM.
SO THAT’S NOT REALLY AN
ANSWER.
BUT IF WOMEN SAID I FIND
THAT EMPOWERING JUST AS I
FIND IT EMPOWERING TO WEAR
CLOTHING THAT MILLION OF
MUSLIM WOMEN ARE FORCED TO
WEAR WOMEN IN ORDER TO BE
MODEST SOMEHOW EMPOWERING?
>> FOR SOME REASON IT’S NOT
THAT SIMPLE.
IT’S NOT BLACK AND WHITE.
FOR SOME WOMEN IT IS INDEED
EMPOWERING.
AND FOR OTHERS IT IS NOT.
AND IT REALLY IS A MATTER OF
PERSPECTIVE AS TO WHERE YOU
ARE.
LET’S TALK ABOUT YOU.
>> Tucker: WHAT FEMALE
MUTILATION?
>> TALK ABOUT MEN, THEY ARE
IN THE SUBWAY AUGUST DAYS, I
FEEL SO BAD FOR AMERICAN MEN
WITH THEIR SUITS AND THEIR
TIES.
>> Tucker: I FEEL BAD FOR
THEM TOO PROBABLY FOR OTHER
REASONS.
>> YOU ARE LETTING SOCIETY
TELL YOU HOW YOU SHOULD
DRESS.
>> Tucker: TAKE IT PAST THIS
IDEA TRYING TO ON
OPEN-MINDED MAN, MODERN MAN.
THE IDEA THAT A GARMENT THAT
A RELIGION HAS FORCED WOMEN
TO WEAR FOR MORE THAN A
THOUSAND YEARS BECAUSE THEY
ARE WOMEN, FORCING THEM TO
BE MODEST, IS SOMEHOW
EMPOWERING FOR WOMEN.
I MEAN, DO YOU THINK THAT,
FOR EXAMPLE, WOMEN ARE ASKED
TO WALK BEHIND THEIR
HUSBANDS OR IN SOME
COUNTRIES YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO DRIVE OR VOTE.
UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES,
CAN THAT BE EMPOWERING?
CAN FEMALE GENDER MUTILATION
BE EMPOWERING?
THAT’S COMMON?
ISLAMIC COUNTRY.
>> THOSE ARE QUITE EXTREME
EXAMPLES THAT YOU ARE TRYING
TO COMPARE.
>> Tucker: NO.
I DON’T KNOW WHY.
THEY ARE ALL FEATURES OF THE
SAME RELIGION AND THEY ARE
ALL GENDER SPECIFIC.
SO I DON’T KNOW -- I MEAN, I
THINK THEY ARE EXTREME, TOO.
I THINK THE HIJAB IS
EXTREME.
YOU DON’T FOR SOME REASON
AND I DON’T KNOW WHY.
>> AS I SAID, THERE ARE
WOMEN WHO DO FIND IT
EMPOWERING.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, IT’S
REALLY NOT THE TOP ISSUE.
I DON’T GO TO WORK EVERY DAY
AND THINK ABOUT WHAT
WARDROBES WOMEN ARE WEARING
AND WHAT IT REPRESENTS.
>> Tucker: OH, REALLY?
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A HUGE
PART OF WOMEN’S LIBERATION
ACTUALLY.
>> A BIG PART OF WOMEN’S
LIBERATION IS MAKING SURE
THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT ROLL
BACK OUR RIGHT TO FULL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE.
>> Tucker: ABORTION, RIGHT.
>> I GO TO WORK EVERY DAY TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO CLOSE THE
WAGE GAP.
>> Tucker: I’M STARTING TO
THINK CARE MORE ABOUT
IDENTITY POLITICS THAN